it took a while to get beyond the
beautiful award back into New York but a
good evening my name is hector ericsson
mendoza and i am the executive director
of the Hispanic link journalism
foundation the foundation was set up
about five years ago to help Hispanics
who are interested in pursuing a career
in communications get that opportunity
both educational and professionally and
it's a it's a great pleasure to welcome
Juan back to Washington DC and I think
you're in for a good talking-to it also
gives me great pleasure to introduce
Manny Meadowvale who is president of the
National Puerto Rican Coalition to say a
few words as well Manny
that was quick thank you and by the way
my most memorable award for Juan
Gonzales is the one we gave him last
year the National Puerto Rican Coalition
was honored to bestow on Juan one of our
life achievement awards which we hand
out every two years and we did so at our
annual conference in Puerto Rico last
year I I take great pleasure in being
here today having known one for many
many years originally in New York or
myself we've been through a lot of
stories about the Big Apple and about
the Puerto Rican community in particular
and it is about time that we had a book
like this written by someone like Juan
Gonzalez who has a very unique but I
believe real perspective on our life as
Latinos in the United States and and one
you know we last year started our own
journalist scholarship at the National
quarter eating coalition we're now in
this summer we have a journalism fellow
at NPR C and we have that individual who
comes out of one of the universities be
responsible for our own newsletter at
NPR so we're looking forward this year
to having another journalist fellow and
we also look forward to working with
Juan to make sure that his work of
literature a
about our community about our
aspirations about our contributions is
read by as many in America as possible
gracias I believe I have the honor of
introducing our other co-host the
tonight Nancy Baca who is the president
of the National Journalists Association
Nancy please hello my name is Nancy Baca
I'm president of the National
Association of Hispanic Journalists and
I'm also the current president of unity
journalists of color unity is made up of
the National Association of Hispanic
Journalists the National Association of
Black Journalists the asian-american
Journalists Association and the Native
American Journalists Association I have
some very special thanks tonight to
Hispanic link journalism Foundation and
to the National Puerto Rican Coalition
for co-sponsoring this event tonight it
is my honor to introduce tonight's guest
Juan Gonzalez columnist for the New York
Daily News and the author of the new
book harvest of empire a history of
Latinos in America I'm very proud to say
that Juan is a founding member of the
National Association of Hispanic
Journalists and he is also a co-founder
of unity journalists of color along with
will Sutton the president of the
National Association of Black
Journalists who is in the back of the
room wave to everyone will quite simply
juan is one of the most important
journalists in this country right now
and the fact that he is Latino and his
importance to the nation's growing
Latino community is immeasurable
particularly in the New York Region if
you don't believe me just read his
column and The Daily News for proof and
if you still don't believe me read his
new book for even further proof harvest
a vampire the new book that we are that
we have copies of available outside in
case you want one
is examines the history of Latinos in
the United States and the Americas
starting from the Spanish and English
conquest to the present day
it is the must read whether you're
Latino or not so it is my pleasure to
turn the mic over to Juan Gonzalez who
will speak for about 20 to 25 minutes
and then take some questions and then
autograph all the books that you're
going to buy thank you what well I want
to thank the neh J and all MyID
journalism colleagues that I see here
the Hispanic a link of foundation and
the national puerto rican coalition all
organizations that over the years i've
not only have i participated her done
what I could to help their endeavors but
have played important roles in the
Puerto Rican Latino experience in
America I'm just gonna take a little bit
about this book and how it developed and
what I've tried to do and then I'm just
gonna open it up to whatever questions
or comments you might have though it's
taken me about 10 years to produce this
book it actually the idea sort of
developed in late 1990 early 1991 when
my newspaper assigned me to cover an
event that actually occurred in the
South Bronx but had ramifications far
beyond the South Bronx some of you may
remember it was called the happy land
social club fire it was a a small
illegal social club in the South Bronx
where a jilted lover who happened to be
a Cuban immigrant who had come over Mary
on the Mariel boatlift in 1980 got upset
at his girlfriend for dumping him and
proceeded to pour some gasoline in the
entrance of the social club where she
was a hatcheck girl and set the place on
fire after she'd had him evicted from
the social club he didn't intend to
the fire ended up killing 87 people that
were inside one Saturday night into
Sunday morning and the next day I got a
call from next morning I got a call from
my editor who wanted me to immediately
jump on a plane and head to Honduras
because it turned out that of the 87
people who died in the fire 65 of them
were immigrants from Honduras because it
would it was an it was a Honduran social
club in the middle of South Bronx now
someone who has grown up in New York all
my life
and thought I knew New York pretty well
I had no idea that there was a fairly
large Honduran community tucked away in
a section of the South Bronx which is
pretty much known as a Puerto Rican or
Dominican Puerto Rican and Dominican
neighborhood so I headed off to San
Pedro Sula in Honduras and to Porto
Cortez and to poetry videos because my
editors wanted me to do a series of
columns on who were these people who
died in the fire how did they get to the
South Bronx because many of them were
undocumented or illegal immigrants and
so I spent a couple of weeks going back
and forth to the homes of these
immigrants waiting for the caskets to
come so that the nation of Honduras
which had suffered this immense tragedy
could bury its children who had gone off
to a North Bay and in the process I was
in a puerto cortes
driving from one family to another to
the home of one family to another when I
happened to be driving by a a free-trade
zone or export processing zone as
they're known in political tests and it
just was around noon and as I'm driving
by suddenly I see thousands and
thousands of young women pouring out of
onto the road and I could see that they
were coming out of all these factories
in this industrial park and I stopped
for a while just because I was so
shocked at the sheer numbers of of them
and talk to them a little bit and I
began that's how I discovered the
preacher
particle tariffs and of course they were
all sewing garments or producing
electrical electronic supplies for
American companies or a lot of them were
South Korean or Taiwanese middlemen
manufacturers but all of it was being
produced for the United States and they
were working for basically two dollars a
day as I went to port radios and which
is the agricultural area of Honduras and
came across the United brands the
plantations that uh United brands now
Chiquita but it's changed his name many
times it used to be United Fruit keeps
changing his name so people don't
remember what it used to do but I think
that one of the things that I discovered
in under trying to grasp all of these
folks who had left Honduras the most
poignant I think a memory that I have is
uh on a day off before we headed back
for the United States my frittata that
my photographer and I decided to go to
La Vina dekopon
the Mayan ruins of koh phangan and we we
took the drive out near the Honduran
border and and there was a young kid was
about 13 years old selling without
volcanic rocks basically to the tourists
and as we came out of the Mayan ruins
and and this this kid tried to sell us
some rocks and I looked at him and I
said why would I want to buy a rock he
said oh well you know the kid says I
went you know you don't know how far
into the mountains I had to go to get
this rock and I said how much do you
want for this and he said he wanted a
fallin beat us and that time the Olympia
was 25 cents so I said quality that's a
dollar for a rock that you just picked
up on the ground and so he's explaining
to explain to me and why how valuable
the rock was and I said how come you
aren't in school and he said well I
don't go to school my mother maybe will
take will send me next year and I said
what does your father do and he he said
he works for United brands and
I said what how much does your father
make and he said he makes seven limpid
as a day so I said so in other words if
you sell two of these rocks today you
will make more money than your father
does working in the plantation and he
says yeah but I haven't sold any rocks
today and so obviously I bought a I
bought a rocket and photographer Boyd
Iraq and the kid made more money that
day than his father and I say this
because for to understand the Latino
experience in America you have to do two
things you have to understand that
Latinos in America our heart still of
the Latin American experience there has
been an enormous explosion of Latino
population in the United States in the
last 50 years an explosion of such
dimensions that it is totally changing
the nature of American society we know
the numbers you know give or take in
your cluding Puerto Rico if you're not
including Puerto Rico there's about 30
million Latinos in the United States
right now and and but however by year
2050 out of 400 million people living in
the United States 100 million will be
Latinos one out of every four in the
entire nation we're not talking about
New York and LA I forget what those
numbers are going to be like or or Texas
or we're just talking in the entire
nation one out of every four people will
be of Latino origin so that the change
this and this explosion has occurred
largely since World War two at a
breathtaking speed and so that one of
the things I began to understand is that
unless you have a grasp of what is going
on in Latin America today and has been
going on now for a good hundred years or
so you will not understand the the
Latino presence in the United States
it's not that somebody was sitting on a
porch in important
or in or in Guatemala City or in some or
in some a country village in Puebla and
said I think I go to the United States
tomorrow you know but that what's
happened is enormous economic and social
forces have been at play that have
distorted and deformed the economies of
Latin America to the point that the
desperation now that is in many of these
countries is of mind-boggling
proportions you're talking about nations
where people when they are working are
making two and three dollars a day I
remember being in the Dominican Republic
in 1992 and there was a medical there
was a doctor strike throughout the
entire Dominican public and many of the
doctors worked for the government they
were making a dominican doctor in 1992
was making about a hundred and twenty
dollars a month in Dominican pesos
translating to US dollars so a Dominican
kitchen worker in New York City can make
more money than a Dominican doctor in
the Dominican Republic so why would
anyone stay in the Dominican Republic
working as a doctor when you go to New
York and work as a taxi driver or as a
as a kitchen worker and make far more
money and the reality is that right now
the lat Latinos of the United States are
keeping many of their home countries
afloat the number one source of income
in salvador today is the money that
Salvadorans sent back to their families
the number two source of income in the
dominican republic is the money that
Dominicans in the United States and back
to their families in Mexico I think it's
number three in Haiti it's number one
Latinos in the United States right now
the estimates are the Tomas Rivera
Center did a study that showed about I
think it was six five point something
billion dollars it's in my
with the exact number of the annual
remittances that Latinos are sending
back to their home countries but they're
not even counting the approximately 800
million that are being sent by Cubans in
the United States to their families back
in Cuba or any of the other countries
that have fewer because they were
concentrating basically on essential
American to Caribbean so you're talking
about maybe seven billion dollars a year
in annual remittances being sent by
Latinos in the United States back to
their families far greater than any
foreign aid that the United States
government is giving to Latin America
the Latinos in the u.s. are giving to
their own people and their own families
to keep their countries out of even die
more dire economic calamity so to
understand the Latino presence in the
United States you must understand first
the US presence in Latin America so what
I have tried to do with this book is
I've tried to first of all go beyond
just the big three you know people say
what's different about your books is put
a bunch of books written on those well
well first of all beyond the big three I
mean Mexicans Puerto Ricans and Cubans
that's the big three Latino by GM Ford
and Chrysler right and go beyond those
to the incredible diversity and richness
of the Latino experience so that I have
I deal with Dominicans I deal with
Colombians and panamanians and
Salvadorans and-and-and Guatemalans to
to show the enormous diversity that has
occurred in this huge mass migration and
what I do with each Latino group is I
attempt to go back first to the country
I focus in on what I call those beyond
eros the pioneers of each migration and
I try to focus on one family a group of
individuals who were involved initially
in the first wave of the mass migration
and I asked them well why did you come
what was happening in your country what
conditions made you forced you to leave
when you came to this country where to
just settle and why did you settle in
those particular cities why there's so
many Salvadorans in Los Angeles and Long
Island and Washington DC
and you know and so many Guatemalans in
Houston and and in Chicago and and so
many Puerto Ricans in New York and in
Philadelphia and and when you got there
how were you received by white society
how were you received by black society
how were you received by other Latinos
what kinds of institutions did you build
uh and how did you overcome your
obstacles what was your process of
integration or lack of integration into
American society and and I try to do
that with each of the groups to show the
enormous diversity that are enriched
mist that there is in the Latino
experience and I also but go back even
earlier though because the book is
divided up into three sections which are
called
roots branches and harvest the root
section attempts to look at the
experience in the womb the American womb
the colonial period of both Anglo
America and Latin America and how did
the conquest by both the English in the
Spanish and the intermixing with or lack
of inter mixing with Native Americans
and and Africans who were brought as
slaves and the period of colonial
conquest and expansion how did that
period in the womb shape the attitudes
and the viewpoints and the klenda and
the cultural beliefs of what is now
Latin America and Anglo America so I go
a little bit into that history but even
more importantly within the Latino the
within the Latino with a presence in the
US how did territorial expansion of the
United States and this is the other big
theme of the book Empire that that's why
it's called harvest of empire because
the huge presence of Latinos in the
United States is a direct result of the
territorial expansion of the United
States I believe and of the the movement
of the United States from a yeoman's
Republic in the original 13 colonies to
a world empire today we don't like to
call ourselves an empire but we are the
most powerful and prosperous nation the
world has ever seen in the process of
that
we have conquered a lot of people we
have dominated a lot of people when I
say we I mean the United States as a
nation and that process of conquests has
led to the the annexing of territories
and peoples and and I believe and and of
course after the Cologne the great
colonial period our system of domination
is a lot more sophisticated we don't
need to send armies we just call in
loans and it has the same devastating
effect and and I think that that part of
the process of understanding the
American Empire the era in which we live
is that the people who are coming to
this country are precisely coming from
the countries that were most dominated
by the United States often occupied
Puerto Rico Cuba the Dominican Republic
Nicaragua Honduras Panama Colombia
Colombia because Colombia remember
people forget that Panama used to be
part of Colombia in fact Panama was
created by Teddy Roosevelt to build the
Panama Canal and that was taken from
Colombia in a false independence revolt
in in 1903 so that if we see the
countries from which the largest group
of Latinos come is precisely those
countries that were most dominated or
controlled by the United States just as
in France they're worried about the
Algerians and the Tunisians because
those were their former colonies and in
England they were worried about the
Pakistanis and the Jamaicans and the
Indians because they were their former
colonies people tend to migrate from the
third world to the very metropolis of
the countries that once dominated them
and that is why you have such a huge
Latino presence but more more
importantly it's not just it is the that
there is I trace I believe me I spent a
lot of time on this I trace the actual
processes by which people began to come
here because the needs of empire
required labor labor migration huge
labor recruitment programs I remember
the 1970s being an hour they up was
Balika and hearing sound trucks comes
through this little town
the western end of Puerto Rico come to
work in the United States come down to
the town Plaza sign up free travel
expenses to come and work in the United
States the the Porto Rican communities
of Kennett Square Pennsylvania mushroom
workers from a mushroom workers Vineland
New Jersey former apple and strawberry
pickers Haverstraw New York all of these
communities developed as a result of
massive labor migration programs and
then the migrants settled and developed
the Puerto Rican community same thing
all over the southwest and I document
though the workers that enemy Ford
recruited to Detroit that Bethlehem
Steel recruited to to Bethlehem
Pennsylvania Mexicans thousands of
Mexicans that Beth the Bethlehem Steel
recruited to Bethlehem Pennsylvania and
I show exactly how so much of the
migration was a direct result of the
needs of the United States for labor at
different periods of time in fact there
was also cross Caribbean labor migration
between 1904 and 1914 to build the
Panama Canal one of the great
engineering marvels in world history
35,000 West Indians were recruited by
the u.s. Panama Canal Company to go from
Barbados and Jamaica to go to Panama to
build the canal the 35,000 workers
brought their their wives and their
children a total of a hundred and thirty
thousand people were moved from the
english-speaking West Indies and put
right in the middle of Panama and after
the canal was built they stayed and they
totally changed the racial ethnic and
religious composition of Panama because
the the West Indian workers were
english-speaking were Protestants and
were largely black the Panamanians of
the time were largely Indians and
mestizos and Spanish speak and Catholic
huge ethnic conflicts were created all
to meet the needs of the United States
of America to build a canal and five
thousand Puerto Ricans were recruited in
the early 1900
the u.s. sugar Growers Association to go
to Hawaii to cut cane so there's a huge
Puerto Rican community in Hawaii as a
result of the labor recruitment programs
of the sugar growers in Hawaii and I can
go on and on and give you all the
examples and the rest of them are in the
book but basically the the Latino
migrations in large part were responding
to the needs of Empire either in terms
of labor or in terms of resolving
political problems so therefore you have
the huge Dominican migration in nineteen
in the 1960s after Trujillo was
assassinated and there was a revolt to
restore President Juan Bosch to power
and one side laws in the United States
let all these Dominicans come into the
country to stave off further revolution
the Cubans who came in the early 1960s
because of the revolution of the Castro
Revolution and the United States wanting
to basically provide an outlet to
diffuse a political situation and bring
in people who had basically been on the
side the foreign managers of American
companies in Puerto Rico the former
Batista soldiers that was the early
migration of course changed and and the
Nicaraguans and the Salvadorans who and
the Guatemalans who came in the 80s as a
result of civil wars in each of those
countries which can be traced whose
roots can be traced back to our own
governments meddling in the affairs and
support of dictators in all those
countries so that either
the Latino migrations were a result of
economic needs of Empire or they were
the result of political needs of Empire
but they were the result of the needs of
the United States most of which American
people had no idea no idea about because
they weren't getting much information in
the local press or the or the popular
dime-store novels and of course
Hollywood films of the day but anyway
that's basically what I try to do so
that history the connection between
Latin America and Latinos in the u.s.
how the Latino communities developed and
and finally the last section is called
harvest which is basically what tested
all is done to the United States and in
there
I have a series of chapters to deal with
how America is changing and and how the
Latino presence is doing enormous ly
change in the country so I have a
chapter on politics in Latinos and the
enormous growth of political power of
Latinos and how that's affecting
everything I go up to the 96
presidential elections and have a little
bit sort of look looking at 2000
elections there's a chapter on
immigration and how immigrant immigrant
policy in the country has been is is
actually you know the anti-american
fervor is over when I started writing
the book he was at high tide you know we
had all the legislation in there early
90s and then of course culminating in 96
but you know you're not hearing anything
much anti immigrants stuff anymore
and I explained why because clearly this
country does not have a this country has
a labor shortage it does not have a a
problem of a labor surplus it has a
labor shortage that every major
industrial country that went through
World War two is facing now is the baby
boomers getting ready to retire and so
that this country needs more workers
from abroad it doesn't need fewer ones
and that and the other problem is that
the huge anti-immigrant push of the 90s
had a backfire effect and hundreds of
thousands of Latinos who were in this
country temporarily and never had any
intention of becoming citizens as a
result of all the anti-immigrant laws
were forced to become citizens you know
there have been studies that show that
Mexicans who were in this country for
ten years had a seven percent
naturalization rate before 96 after all
the anti-immigrant laws they all had to
become citizens if they were going to
defend themselves against possible
repercussions so what happened is there
was a rush to citizenship all those
people who became citizens starting in
the in the mid 90s immediately
registered to vote and they immediately
registered to vote Democratic so boom
California's governorship changed and
and Clinton
had a huge increase in his Latino vote
in 96 so that the immigration backlash
of Latinos now has ended the the
anti-immigrant fervor and now you have
the new enlightened Republicans
represented by Reardon in Los Angeles
Giuliani in New York Bush the bushes all
of whom talk about inclusion and the
necessity to reach out and and and you
also have the even the Democrats the
afl-cio recently changed digits complete
turnaround in its immigration policy and
now is calling for amnesty for
undocumented workers and is calling for
the right of undocumented workers to
organize so both the Democrats and the
Republicans counting the numbers have
decided that they've got to change their
policies so there's immigration there's
language and culture and this is the
last point I'm making that I'm gonna
open it up because I think I I do a lot
in that language and culture chapter on
the misconceptions about language in the
United States in my view there have been
three separately related conflicts that
deal with language policy in the United
States there is the the language
conflicts of the immigrants who were
voluntarily came to this country became
citizens and they've always had some
conflict or other about their
relationship to their native tongue you
know when the United States became a
republic 10% of the people spoke German
and German was spoken a huge portions of
Pennsylvania and they were bought the
first bilingual program was established
at the University of Pennsylvania in
1700 and and the immigrants have always
had a a a language conflict but
basically have always agreed that
English is the main language of the
country then there are the the the
language experience of the African
slaves who all came here forcibly all
speaking different languages but not
only we're not we're not allowed to
maintain their own languages were
forbidden from
learning how to read and write English
because that was considered possibly
subversive to the slave system and there
was a subjugation of the
african-american in terms of language
and then there are the the language
experience of what I call the annexed
people's now this is important to
understand the annexed peoples were the
people who were already living on the
current territory of the United States
speaking their own language and they
didn't go to the United States the
United States came to them expansion
enveloped them the French Creoles of
Louisiana all of the Native Americans
those Mexicans of the Southwest and the
Puerto Ricans of Puerto Rico the Puerto
Ricans of Puerto Rico was speaking
Spanish for four hundred years before
the United States arrived in 1898 and
tried to immediately change the language
of his people to English including the
public schools in the case of the
annexed People's Congress established
dominion over them declared them
citizens all of them with the exception
of well even the Native Americans but
declared them citizens didn't ask them
to change their language just said from
now on your citizens after 1848 the
Mexicans of Southwest territory your
your citizens after 1917 the Puerto
Rico's your citizens and as a result for
the annex peoples their language is
their original language and the in case
of Spanish Spanish is the second
domestic language of this country it's
the second domestic language of this
country and once you accept that the
Mexicans and the Puerto Ricans we're
already speaking Spanish when they were
incorporated into the territory into the
territory of the United States
then you recognizes the legitimacy to
the Spanish language that is not a
foreign language Spanish is not a
foreign language in the United States it
is a secondary language of some of the
annexed peoples of the United States and
therefore anyone who comes afterwards
and happens to also speak Spanish they
fall within the the the the same rubric
and it's also the number-one language of
the way
and hemisphere so that you cannot equate
the spanish-language question and that's
why you have networks and and this huge
proliferation of Spanish newspapers and
everything else because in South Texas
today when you go to McAllen Brownsville
Harlingen Rio Grande City all ego pass
when you go through that whole strip of
South Texas the people were 90 percent
Mexican back before it was US
territories and 90 percent Mexican today
they all speak Spanish
and yes they speak English too because
they're part of United States but it's
not a foreign language there it can't be
and so that the language issue it's been
so stereotyped and so simplified that
the important complexity of it and the
indifference is in language policy and
most important United States never
recognizes language discrimination
it recognizes racial discrimination it
recognizes national discrimination
recognizes ethnic discrimination and the
right to be free of this but doesn't
recognize the right to be free of
language discrimination so that Latinos
in the United States Mexicans are an
ethnic minority Puerto Ricans are an
ethnic minority Cubans are an ethnic
minority but all the Latinos together
are linguistic minority within the
United States and that they suffer not
only the particular racial and ethnic
discrimination that they may suffer from
but they also suffer linguistic
discrimination as a group and I think
that understanding that and being able
to find the solutions to deal with that
that issue is critical to understanding
why Latinos get so upset and why Anglo
Americans get so upset over this issue
of language because in a multinational
state like the United States language is
a a more critical question than as I say
in France or it is in England or places
where basically the populations malmo
overwhelmingly have spoken the same
language throughout their history anyway
so that's and then the last two chapters
are basically a free trade the final
conquest of Latin America where I go
into why I believe that free trade is
actually contributing to more Latino
migration to the United States and
fomenting it
and finally the final chapter is a
Puerto Rico USA possessed and unwanted
and it's all about what is the United
States going to do with Puerto Rico it's
been in the territorial possession for
100 years 102 years now 102 years and
neither the United States government nor
the Puerto Rican government can or and
people can figure out how this
relationship is going to end and you
know it's proof that getting married is
easily getting divorced
acquiring a possession is a lot easier
than divesting yourself of it and and
but the reality is that contrary to
popular belief that the popular belief
is of Puerto Rico's is either a big
eight vacation sore spot or a dependent
of welfare dependent country Puerto Rico
is the and I document it all in the book
it is the single largest source of
profit for American companies in history
in history Puerto Rico makes more money
net in 1995 alone fifteen billion
dollars in net profit to American
companies as a result of operations in
Puerto Rico compared to like six billion
in federal transfers to the island
because you don't include things like
Social Security cuz people pay into
Social Security so they deserve to get
back especially if they're American
citizens but the there's a net profit to
the United States from the holding of
Puerto Rico the only problem is that the
administration of the colony comes from
the federal government's Treasury the
profits go into those of private
corporations so it's a transfer of money
from the American people through Puerto
Rico being laundered back into the
United States as profits for
pharmaceuticals and other American
companies and I document exactly how
it's done in the book and why the United
States and Puerto Rico have to figure
out what to do about the last remaining
colony that our nation holds and a
single largest source of profit in its
history on anyway that's what the book
is about it covers a whole range of
issues and and it's really not that
long but it's chock-full of information
and and I just leave it at that and and
open it up to whatever questions you all
might have thank you Donnell with all
these journalists yeah I'm gonna shift
gears a little bit on and start talking
about journalism and what's happening
with Hispanics in the field of
journalism in the United States you've
been a journalist since I've known you
at least two decades now and you're
still in the business but for some
reason the field is having a heck of a
time either attracting journalists or
maybe it's repelling them what's your
view on why mainstream media does not
have more Hispanics in its City rooms
and in its higher level of management
well you know editors and managers hire
and promote people who they believe
basically the higher promoting their own
image it's the rare secure editor or
manager who hires or promotes someone
who challenges them who-who is radically
different from them who who in one way
or another makes them uneasy the rear
and the reality is that that's why you
get a homogenous ation of newsrooms
generally speaking because they're it's
you know it's I've just found that that
throughout that editors feel more
comfortable with people that are like
them and unfortunately because so many
of the editors and and managers in
newsrooms and television stations are
are of the same economic and social and
racial break makeup that that then
replicates itself and the only time you
had any real
substantive change was that one asked me
when asked nee adopted its its goals but
when some of the major media companies
began putting affirmative action as part
of the MBOs
of of managers for them to to judge
their bonuses at the end of the year
then suddenly you started seeing huge
spurts the economic factor sort of began
to have an impact on these editors and
but I thought my suspicion is that that
that criteria in terms of MBOs for a lot
of the editors and station managers has
fallen by the wayside so you're
beginning to see backtracking and I
understand will was telling me that the
report that came out today for the first
time ever the number of
african-americans has actually declined
or the percentage of african-americans
in journalism is actually declines and I
think that there there's the country is
changing rapidly and there are those who
say hey that opens up new possibilities
and new challenges for greater democracy
and there are others who say this is a
subversion and a destruction of society
as we know it and and I and and there's
are those people who react against it
unfortunately we're in the period right
now where the reaction is greater than
those who see potential but I'm
confident that the sheer numbers of the
growth of the population and the Latino
and the african-american and the Asian
population of the country it's it's an
irresistible force as long as there is
such a huge gap between the wealth and
the advance West and the poverty in the
third world the people of the third
world are going to keep coming to the
metropolis and the metropolis is are
going to be changed
it may take 50 years and may take a
hundred years but the viewpoints in the
metropolis will change you can't change
you cannot stop people from trying to
survive and the journalists who are much
you know they're not in survival
situations journalists actually live
pretty well but they reflect
to a great degree what is occurring in
the in the rest of the third world
and so long I think it's I think it's
changes changes change you can't you
know you could try to like hold it back
for a little bit but sooner or later it
it continues moving forward so I think
things are are going to change
substantially because newspapers and TV
stations will die or lose ratings or and
unless they begin to reflect more
accurately what this I mean one of the
interesting on the media side Clara
Rodriguez professor forums done a very
excellent study on the media and Latinos
and and she discovered that the the
presence of Latinos and in films and
television in the United States was
greater in the 1940s and more positive
overwhelmingly in the 1940s and 1950s
then it's then it's been in the last
three decades and she gives terrific
examples just to give you the kind of
roles that Latinos had you know in back
in the in the 50s on television and if I
could find it just because I mean
astounded me when I didn't realize that
things don't always like move in a
progression you know they sometimes go
back and then they go forward but here
are some of the some of the roles and
some of you are old enough to remember
these among the great Latino parts in
those years we're talking where Anthony
Quinn is the daring back arrow in the
Oxbow incident 1943 Ricardo Montalban in
the hope as the heroic Mexican
government official on border incident
1949 Jose Ferrer as the oscar-winning
Cyrano de
Iraq in 1950 Kati hirato is the savvy
businesswoman in high noon 1950 two sets
of Romero Duncan a Nando and Gilbert
Rowland all of who starred in the Cisco
Kid television series and perhaps the
most famous of all Desi Arnaz as the
charming but hot-tempered Latin husband
and I Love Lucy these were all terrific
parts in the mass television films for
Latinos in the 40s and 50s now when you
look at the 1970s you've got such
classics as Dirty Harry the French
Connection of the new Centurions 7up
badge 373 magnum force death wish
boardwalk the exterminator Fort Apache
the Bronx colors and falling down all of
whom were films that showed Latinos in
the most negative criminal and
threatening images and forget about
television series I mean except for
Chico and the man you could barely find
any Latinas on television series so why
why how is it possible that in 1940s and
50s when there were fewer Latinos in the
country television was showing and meet
the film's was showing a positive image
and as a number of Latinos grew suddenly
the images became darker and and in more
threatening and menacing well Clara
Rodriguez posits that she believes that
in 40s and 50s during World War two and
the Korean War a period when the United
States depended more on Latin America
for sources of labor and for economic
and material support and the good
neighbor policy you had to have a more
positive image of Latin Americans among
Americans because the country needed
Latin America more and that in the 70s
80s and 90s when the growth of the
Latino population was really creating
more conflict that that Hollywood began
to pursue really in essence in sight or
create fear among white America about
the Latino population you know I don't
know if that's
all that simple and and clear-cut and I
think that there are a lot of other
things involved but is there's no doubt
that that the movies and television play
a huge role in the shaping of American
attitudes toward everything not just
Latinos and journalism is only one
aspect of this huge communications and
social conditioning situation because
you you remember all the great stories
and Miami Herald and New York Times and
all these other newspapers a few years
ago about the hordes of immigrants
coming into the coming across the border
and and landing at the airports and and
not and in overstaying their visas and
and they were prize-winning stories and
and now you know here people anymore but
people are still coming people are still
coming but there's not a peep anymore
why because now the I&S says and and
Alan Greenspan says that the country
needs more workers because otherwise
it's going to be inflationary pressures
on wages so that there's a labor
shortage this unemployment is like
almost down to nothing so you got
anymore workers since the same thought
Eidos keep coming it's just that the
political needs of the nation and are
changing yeah
the Asian immigrants keep it in mind
that I recognized that that is
incredible diversity that is being put
under that label and another people
students say but why the first public
cross-section that again is praised
sometimes non-discrimination is
different for Asian Americans Hispanics
in a zillion
well I mean as you say there's a huge
diversity in the Asian in the Asian
population and then this whole idea the
model minority viewpoint has a lot of
big problems or kinks in it when you
start looking at the situation of
laotians and Cambodians and and and
other Asians I think that that one of
the things that I discovered I tried to
explain in Latino
migrations that migrations are not just
ethnic and character they're very often
class in character and that people
sometimes see the outer ethnic
perspective but do not see the inner
class content of a migration to give you
an example they've been about five
different Cuban migrations to the United
States in the late 19th century a
100,000 Cubans came to the United States
during the period of the war against
independence against Spain they were
largely tobacco workers they were an
industrial workforce they settled in New
Orleans and Tampa that created Ybor City
and Key West and New York and and that
was a that was a a mex that was a Cuban
working-class migration the 1959
migration was largely upper-class the
the the the the upper crust of Cuban
society
later on as you went into the 60s you
started getting more of a of a more
working-class migration in that Mario
boatlift was the the lowest classes of
Cuban society many of them are released
from the jails and people who were
unemployed all of those different Cuban
migrations they all reflect I mean there
are conflicts between the Mariel Cubans
and and those who came earlier because
Mario Cubans world darker-skinned and
and suffered to some degree racism from
the wider Cubans who came in post 1959
so that I think in the Asian migrations
you've had similar things some of them
like the Vietnamese migrations were
largely more upper class and middle
class people the Korean migrations the
large a lot most of the Korean migrant
came short after Jimmy Carter started
threatening to pull US troops out of
Korea and many as I discovered when I
was a young reporter in Philadelphia in
the late 1970s were from a middle-class
and upper-class backgrounds and many
settled in african-american and Latino
communities where they developed stores
because I was the easiest place the
cheapest place to develop stores and the
conflicts that developed between Koreans
and african-americans and Koreans and
Puerto Ricans in some of these
neighborhoods wasn't necessary it had
the appearance of an ethnic conflict but
a lot of it was a class conflict of
middle class people who were suddenly D
classed
and had to and had to fall into into
lower economic strata and resented it
and didn't like having to to to to cater
to the black and Latino communities in
which they were in wasn't so much it
looks like an ethnic conflict but it was
actually a class conflict occurring just
as the Cubans who came in the 1960s to
those upper-class Cubans who came in the
1960s many settled in Puerto Rican
communities huge conflicts developed
between Puerto Ricans and Cubans but but
they they appear to be ethnic conflicts
but they were really more class
conflicts in that many of the Cubans
were from upper-class strata now there
was suddenly they were a jewelry store
owner and a Puerto Rican community or or
a furniture store owner and they didn't
like the jobs that they were in but they
were only doing it temporarily so they
they they didn't serve the customer as
with as much gusto as somebody who saw
it as a career opportunity and therefore
and you had for instance Cubans came to
dominate in Puerto Rico Cubans came to
dominate the entire mass media
television all the reporters and and
sales managers were all Cuban and the
Puerto Ricans were saying where'd all
these Cubans come from and now they're
running everything in our in Armenia it
was at the Cubans were you know I had
already had certain managerial skills
they had training they had they had more
class development and they were able to
thanks the support of the US government
because they were political refugees as
opposed to economic refugees they were
able to together gain a foothold so that
I think that
situation with the asian-americans is a
lot more complex than people make it out
to be and I all when somebody says to me
someone arrives from X country with no
money and developed a store and grows up
rapidly I say what were they doing in
their own country what did their parents
do in that country as one of the great
things that Al Gore has said recently in
terms of understanding the whole issue
of affirmative action in
african-americans is the whole issue of
family wealth and he's repeatedly said
that that african-americans because of
the whole period of slavery never were
able to accumulate wealth within the
family so that you could therefore use
that to to help you advanced generation
over generation so I think that that is
that's my question that sometimes that
in terms of the Asian model minority it
is I mean it costs a lot of money to pay
a coyote from China to get here you know
that is not like a few hundred dollars
to cross the river that's thousands and
thousands of dollars and so that I think
it's a whole different situation with
Asians but I'm not an expert on the
Asian community so yeah Manny promised
that because of the existing job
shortage there's going to be a higher
acceptance of additional what will
amount to additional immigration to the
United States mostly from the southern
hemisphere to us how do you foresee that
affecting the other programs that are
have been created and exist to do
development in Latin America and in
South America AI D the International
Monetary Fund opaque the Caribbean Basin
initiative and and all these economic
programs which supposedly would assist
those other countries the Latin American
countries in South American countries
developed their economy the the reality
is that all these development programs
and I you know making a blanket
statement here but it's in that it's a
kernel truth all these development
programs have very little to do with the
economic development of those nations
and everything to do with the
development of American trade with those
nations and in the new york times review
my book Linda Robinson who I respect
highly she's a great reporter say her
big bone to pick was my criticism of
NAFTA and what NAFTA has done to Mexico
and the United States and and the
reality is that since NAFTA was created
I mean after was created in 1995 for
there were 500,000 roughly give or take
a few thousand macula jobs in Mexico
today there are over a million macula
jobs in Mexico today General Motors is
the single largest private employer in
Mexico
General Motors General Motors has 50
factories along the Mexican border
producing for the United States General
Motors is not there to economically
develop Mexico General Motors is there
to pay Mexican auto workers $10 a day or
$7 a day sort of paying a US automaker
$18 an hour now I perfectly understand
the logic of General Motors wanting to
pay $10 a day instead of $18 an hour you
know if I were if I ran a factory I'd
want to do that too
but you also then have to understand
that you could have to understand the
logic of a Mexican worker saying why
should I stay here and I think $10 a day
when I can go to the United States and
make a minimum 6,000 our you know that's
talking about an any job so that the
reality is that that NAFTA through the
destruction of Mexican agriculture
if you create a half a million more
industrial jobs but you throw a million
Mexican farmers off the land because
American agribusiness can produce wheat
and corn cheaper you got a net loss
you got a net loss of up there's a half
a million more people looking for work
so what's happened is that the economic
development policy
in Latin America of the United States
under the free trade period have all
been geared toward sword expanding
market opportunities for US business not
for the self-sufficient development of
Mexico or any other country I'll give
you one fact to me speaks volumes
knighted nation's Economic Development
Report two-thirds of all the trade in
the world all the foreign trade in the
world is intercompany trade between
multinational corporations and one-third
of all the trade in the world is
intra-company trade between subsidiaries
of the same multinational in other words
its Ford of Brazil shipping parts
between four of the US and Ford of
England right so one-third of all the
foreign trade in the world is
intra-company trade of multinationals so
when you want to lower customs duties
you want to lower the cost of a
multinational company doing business
with itself with its own subsidiaries
because one-third of it that's what it
is so that it has nothing to do with the
economic development of all these
separate countries it has to do with
lowering the cost of global trade for
the major companies in the world and
that's why latin america has continued
to stagnate economically and has an
income levels since 1980 have either
been stagnant or gone down in virtually
every latin-american country even as
they've increasingly privatized and
adopted liberal free-trade policies and
so I think that as I quote ulysses s
grant in in the beginning of of the
chapter on free trade Ulysse says
because this this free trade thing it's
been around as long as capitalism has
been around and ulysses s grant once
said after two centuries england has
found it convenient to adopt free trade
because it thinks that protection can no
longer offer it anything my knowledge of
our country leads me to believe that
within two hundred years when america
has
gotten out of protection all that it can
offer because the United States had
highly protectionist policies throughout
the late 1930 it too will adopt free
trade well grant was wrong it wasn't 200
years was 100 years but but basically
that that's what free trade has always
been the [ __ ] the dominant power in the
world has always pushed for free trade
all the other countries have always had
to try to protect and develop their own
home industries and when England was a
dominant power it pushed free trade and
now the United States is a dominant
power
it pushes free trade and because it's
any soul free as it looks anyway that's
uh that's it and thanks for the
questions and I hope get a chance to
read the book and and urge your friends
too and I guarantee you you'll know a
whole lot more about Latinos after you
read the book that you did before you
may not agree with all my conclusions
but you'll certainly learn more learn a
lot thanks we got books up here too so
wanna consign in this 28 bucks so we
take personal checks and cash he's
finding right here